oh hi i'm chris kohler editor of game
life and tonight we're here at the wired
store in new york city for the grand
opening where i'm going to be
interviewing Alex or gapless the CEO of
harmonics the makers of rock band
I have been playing games my whole life
and even when I was dabbling in
programming writing some adventure games
and stuff and I was younger but when we
started the company we weren't thinking
about that really at all we thought of
ourselves when we started it and to this
day even though we're making games we
still think of ourselves as a music
company not a game company and that was
especially true in the early years
because the for the first four years or
so of our existence we weren't making
games we were just making these kind of
interactive music creative expressive
systems doing some pc cd-rom stuff a
product called the axe which was a
joystick music creation program and some
theme park exhibits and things like that
and it was all just about 34 music
making and not about game play at all in
the late 90s the first music game
started to appear in japan games like
Parappa or beatmania Dance Dance
Revolution and at first I'm kind of
embarrassed to say that at the very
beginning we kind of looked down our
nose at those games because it amused
the form of musical interaction a rhythm
action gameplay that was being pioneered
in those games it was not very
sophisticated as a form of musical
interaction it seemed really simplistic
compared to what we were doing and again
we had this naive sense but what we were
doing was better than that because it
was more complex or more rich in some
way and we had that viewpoint until we
actually played the games and then we
were really struck by how fun they were
and more importantly we were struck by
how there was in these games their games
so there's there are these objective
criteria for success and failure there
are goals you can want you win them
there's something very specific you're
striving for and what really struck us
about that was one most people need that
they don't just want freeform creative
play most people I'm sorry I mean this
is of course not true for everyone but
for most people creative work is
actually work it can be very rewarding
work but it's work and it's often not
entertained and entertainment and it's
critical for stickiness and the desire
to keep doing something again and again
that's I mean how we design games as
game designers is creating those that
hierarchy of goals and achievement as
you work your way through very short
term small goals to large macro goals
over the course of a game
and it had that hierarchy of goals that
we hadn't really appreciated in our form
of work and the final thing we realized
I think was that rhythm action gameplay
wasn't a trivial form of musical
interaction we had been focused before
that on musical creativity and not on
musical performance per se but that
rhythm action was a kind of simulation
of music performance that was legitimate
that felt musical when we were playing
it and so there was a huge you know
lightbulb moment for us in the late 90s
where we realized that we had been on
the wrong track for four years that
music that merging music making and
gameplay were how we were going to
accomplish what we wanted to accomplish
but on a much bigger scale and so at
that point we just redirected the
company and decided to try to bring
music gameplay to the western markets
where there was no success at that point
and to try to advance the genre to the
next level and it was at that point that
we started prototyping the our first
music game which eventually went on to
become frequency which is unpublished
it's interesting what we think about
these games as you know music that you
put into these games or serving one of
two purposes one is if someone's playing
one of these games and they're playing a
song in the game that they already know
and they already love they're just
experiencing it in a new way connecting
to the music on a deeper level it's
already it's music that they already
know and love and they're sort of there
they're resonating with that familiarity
of the music through the gameplay and
it's very different from a second
function that these games play which is
the music discovery aspect of them which
is that you when you play new music that
you you know play in the game music that
you don't already know it's actually
harder to play at first because your
memory and your familiarity with the
song guides you through the gameplay
when you're playing these games you're
playing with your ear as much as you're
playing with your eye I think for us
when we were originally composing the
soundtrack we weren't thinking so much
about the music discovery aspect of it
we were thinking about trying to compile
compile a killer rock soundtrack that
would be as familiar to as many people
as possible and then of course we threw
a few kind of hidden gems on there like
I remember with there's a blue öyster
cult track on
and you know the Blue Oyster Cult track
that everybody you know that his most
famous and popular culture is reaper
right but there was a much better Blue
Oyster Cult track Godzilla which
actually at the protest of our publisher
at the time we insisted go in instead
and we thought was just a much better
song and one of the thing early things
we noticed was like a lot of our fans
flipping out about that song because
they knew the band they had heard of the
band but they had never experienced that
song and they were having a blast
playing it and then I started getting
anecdotal information about like you
know a 40 year old dad who was who was
playing the game and he was totally
psyched because as you know 12 year old
daughter had been playing with him and
now she was like she knew deep purple
lyrics by heart and we really started to
get tuned into this fact that actually
the discovery aspect of music games was
at least as important as the former
aspect because experiencing new music
new music that you haven't heard before
in this form for the first time it's an
incredibly impactful way to experience
that music and it really gets under your
skin and gets inside of you and gets
internalized in a way that it never
would under normal circumstances if you
just hear it on the radio or something
like that the aesthetic design and the
whole kind of framing of guitar hero was
more cartoony kind of meat headed metal
flavor and when we started developing
rock band we wanted to take it in a very
new direction aesthetically and in terms
of the sensibility of the game we wanted
it to feel more authentic more like real
music making as opposed to a caricature
of it we wanted it to have broader more
mainstream appeal beyond just you know
metal and harder and harder classic rock
and so we started going after original
masters rather than covers we've been
working with cover recordings that we
had produced in the studio earlier but
we really felt for the authenticity sake
it had to be master recordings and then
we also started collect you know
compiling sound tracks that were a much
broader and more diverse mix of music
and we felt at the time I remember
thinking that it was pretty risky as
normally when you're thinking about
products design and product marketing
it's all about
focus really understanding a specific
consumer and in designing around that
specific consumer in mind in this case
there was a conscious decision a
conscious decision to go abroad and the
reason that that's risky is because you
know the early Guitar Hero game you knew
if you had like a metal fan or a classic
rock fan or whatever that the vast
majority of the music on that soundtrack
was going to be familiar to that person
and was going to appeal to them and draw
them in and with rock bands the
diversity meant that it was a very
different strategy towards how we were
going to be selling the game to the
market because probably any particular
consumer because of the diversity would
recognize 12 or 15 of the 50 songs on
the soundtrack instead of most of them
and they would be have to be taking a
leap of faith about a lot of the other
music on the soundtrack and then so
you'd have this that the market would be
broken into these pockets of people who
for whom 15 to 20 of the songs on the
soundtrack would be familiar but not all
of them but the reason that we felt that
that was okay was because of it that the
collaborative party nature of the game
that there would be a pollinating effect
of this was a this is a game about four
people are more coming to play music
together or more if you consider the
crowd of people in a room at a party
that they would be selecting me like
each individual be would be selecting
music that they knew and we're familiar
with but they would be playing with with
others and kind of pollinating that
music to other people and this was a bet
that we took in the soundtrack
conception and design but it really we
feel felt it paid off because when rock
band that went on and exploded then that
you know those the anecdotes broadened
as well that you know I mentioned
earlier you'd have the like middle-aged
dad totally psyched that he had
successfully indoctrinated his you know
his 13 year old daughter with deep
purple it went the other way as well
you'd have these teenage girls totally
psyched that they had like gotten their
dad hooked on the AIS and that flow of
music discovery we found was working in
both directions which was incredibly
gratifying realization for us before
guitar hero and rockband and all of this
happens the it was a pretty strained
relationship actually between the record
companies and the game publishers
because generally speaking the game
publishers point of view
that they were like MTV meaning an
excellent promotional opportunity for
the record company so you would have
dialogues between the game publishers in
the record companies where the game
publishers would say look give us these
famous tracks by big bands of yours for
free to stick in our games and it's
worth it for you because millions of
people are going to play our games
they're going to get to know the music
and then they'll go buy it you know the
game publishers were positioning
themselves as MTV or the radio as a
promotional platform which which was
fine as far as it went but it wasn't a
direct business opportunity for the
record companies whereas when music
games started exploding and in
particular when we started working on
rock band again because of how we viewed
it as a music platform and an expansion
of music entertainment we had a very
clear philosophy about how we wanted to
work with the music publishers and the
record labels and the recording artists
which was to deal them in in a
substantial financial way in what we
were doing and that really changed the
tenor of the relationship between game
companies and in the record industry
because for the first time they were
being invited in as material financial
partners in the endeavor and I think
that's what has led to the you know that
the stampede of content onto the rock
band platform over the last year or so
the interesting thing is that as at the
time as the original guitar hero was
starting to snowball into a kind of
phenomenon there was obviously a lot of
the in publishers in the industry the
game publishers were taking notice and
of course Activision bought redoctane
and there were a number of game
publishers who were interested in
acquiring harmonics at the time as well
but we had been talking to MTV for years
and ultimately the reason that it was at
the fit you know harmonics becoming part
of MTV made so much more sense to me
than us becoming part of a game
publisher was because you know as I said
early on we had always and have always
thought of ourselves as a music company
first in a game company second and that
really exciting aspects of the MTV
relationship was that they seem to get
that you know through it through all
levels of MTV there was enthusiasm about
what we were doing as
a new dimension of music or a new
frontier in music and that has really
born itself out in practice as MTV has
stepped in and been enormously helpful
in forging new relationships with major
recording artists and record companies
and so if we're thrilled with how about
the play doh there are several different
axes along which you're going to see
music games advance over the coming
years one is just on the content axis
which is that even though they're you
know nearly 500 songs playable on the
rock band platform etc that's huge by
you know historical standards in the
music game category but if you think
about the entire universe of amazing
music that's out there only the tiniest
sliver of it is available for play an
interactive form right now and so
certainly Harmonix has and will continue
to you know with increasingly
aggressively just try to explode out the
portion of the content of great music
that's out there that is playable in
some kind of interactive form the word
revolution is batted around kibri
cavalierly but I do feel like when
rhythm action gameplay took hold in
Japan in the late 90s that was a
gameplay revolution that there was a
fundamental there was a new cata you
know there had essentially been no
category around this form of game play a
new game play is not invented all that
often for since then since the late 90s
around that time 97 through now there
have been evolutionary steps in the
music game category some of them
significant and there's been a steady
march forward and you know Harmonix has
certainly been trying to do what it can
to to you know push push that frontier
forward in evolving on refining and
experimenting around the fringes with
rhythm action gameplay but at its core
the mechanic is still the same so you
say you want a revolution but I just
wanted to talk of course about the fact
that Harmonix be doing a Beatles game
next year yes please tell us everything
about it well as you know Chris there's
very little I can say about it I thought
this was the unveiling and now not just
yaad I was tricked well but the story
behind it you know the
the inception of the game is kind of
interesting the my boss in the the
president of the music group at MTV is
van Toffler and it turns out he knows
the Harrison family and it was winter of
Wow nearly two years ago that van called
me and he had been on vacation in the
Caribbean somewhere I think and had just
had dinner with the Harrisons and it
turned out that Danny was a you know
huge fan of harmonics games that was
nice to hear and that and that he wanted
to meet and so I met with Danny and we
got to yeah you know we were having fun
brainstorming and it occurred to me that
wait a minute this thing that I've
always assumed would be impossible maybe
isn't actually impossible right now like
maybe it's actually time that we could
make an interactive version of this
incredible music and so we started
talking about it and started gaining
momentum and we envision very early on
we started getting the actual you know
Libyan yoko and lingo and Paul involved
in thinking about this and started
working on early prototypes and it just
started taking on a life of its own and
gaining momentum and after you know a
year and a half or more of kind of
nudging that ball forward very
delicately the stars all aligned and it
finally came together and I got to tell
you it's really it's really a dream
project for me I literally have been
dreaming of an opportunity to work with
this material since I was a child so
yeah boy we can't wait to unveil this
thing next year